trust, believe and follow Islam. Same
time I never converted as a Muslim
because of my parents. So I would like
to know what should I do about it. I'm
working at health and life insurance
company in Sri Lanka.
A company invest the premiums for
government treasury bonds and doing more
business like electronic devices,
hospital foods, cities, exports and
imports etc. I sell more policies
without any kind of extra money. They
only get what they saved for entire term
at maturity. In them hospitalization,
they can settle hospital bill by using a
policy. In death or disability, they can
claim some extra bonus. If someone
thinks it's interest, what can I do for
it?
The question posed by Rashan from Sri
Lanka that
he's Hindu by birth but never believed
in Hinduism
full life and he believed in Islam same
time never converted as a Muslim because
of parents so like to know what should I
do if you believe in Islam and you
believe in the teachings of
Allah subhanana wa tala and The last and
final message, my first request to you
would be that see to you except Islam.
As long as you believe there's one God
and you believe there's no one else that
deserves worship and you believe that
Prophet Muhammad is a messenger of God,
then my request to you would be that
immediately as soon as possible except
Islam because you do not know how long
you will live. I'm not sure whether I
live tomorrow, whether I see tomorrow or
not. So as you said you studied Islam
and you agree with it and you want to
accept Islam. My request to you would be
see to it that you don't delay. Don't
wait for the right occasion or some
birthday of someone else or don't
wait that you'll do it later on. My
advice to you would be that see to it
that you accept Islam as soon as
possible. Coming to the second question
that you involved in some of the
transactions which involves a dBA
there's insurance there are two types of
insurance one is the general insurance
which is there and the other Islamic
insurance called as takaful so if you
involve and if you put something in
takaful or Islamic insurance which takes
care of you but if you go to the
conventional insurance it deals with
ribba and they will have a different
line and that's not acceptable in Islam
because ribba is a new so what we have
to do is if dealing with conventional
insurance we deal with ribba you should
leave it and see to the don't do it
again but if it is somewhat like based
on Islamic Sharia if it's then there's
no problem and it's permitted hope that
answers the